oh my God I cannot believe it you have
just grown up young lady thank you and
you have made it a Family Fare and a
little bit of a day
I see the handsome gym I know he's
pretty unbelievable I'd say you both are
winning on that front and you are
winning when it comes to anola not only
the star of this movie but a producer as
well so you've got to be over the moon
for a sequel I know I know I'm really
grateful and Netflix gave me the
opportunity to create this character
again I started a detective agency
[Music]
you're a girl what do you think it is
that people are connecting and loving
most about Enola home I think there's a
part of the film that the audience feels
like they can connect with Enola because
we're breaking the fourth wall yeah and
um it feels like there's a better
connection between the both when people
especially when young people watch the
film they're like oh she's talking to us
and it feels like you have a
relationship with her you have a
friendship with her and it it really
feels like you're going on the journey
look even grown women feel like they
have a relationship and some sort of
kindred spirit with her and the fact
that your Sidekick is Henry Cavill hello
I know how do you feel like you're up in
the Annie with a sequel though well I
think this time around we're talking
about a real story that really happened
which I think is really important to
shed light on
female workers and the way they were
treated back then in order to improve
now
um so it's a really important story and
a really big message it really is and I
I kind of touched on Henry Cavill I'm
curious since you worked directly with
him he was your big bro in this film did
you know before the rest of us that he
was returning a Superman young lady I
did not know I really did it I really
I really know and I cannot wait for a
third film there's definitely going to
be one I hope so I really hope so have
you wrapped your mind around the final
season of stranger things I have I'm
coming to terms with it slowly so I'm
ready I'm ready all right well you are
just going to continue to shine young
lady thank you very much
[Music]